there's an interesting thing about
English that hardly anyone thinks about
there are two th sounds and you want to
know why it took me twenty one takes to
record this and if you want to know why
it took me twenty two takes to record
this intro you try switching them around
the difference is voicing it's you
making your vocal folds vibrate the
vocal folds are little flaps of mucous
membrane that sit in your larynx so sit
up straight and put your thumb and
fingers gently on your throats like this
you don't actually need to sit up
straight for this but it's good practice
now with me make and hold Earth's sound
like the start of sing ready
you shouldn't feel anything really
happening there but now try this is it
sound like at the start of joints ready
with me feel that vibration this is try
switching between the two
scissors you can feel it turning on and
off that vibration is your vocal folds
flapping around now if you have a quick
search around the web you can find
glorious full-color slow motion video of
vocal folds vibrating and moving
frankly it's quicks me out but it does
show off how much amazing control you
have over those things without even
knowing it if you can hit a good middle
C hmm like that wasn't then you're able
to make them open and close 261 times a
second exactly without even thinking
about it now sometimes you might just
stop voicing entirely oh you might
restrict it and slow it down to create
creaky voice that's connects to the
vocal fry' phenomenon that's been like
making loads of people like really
annoyed
so anyway two very different sounds and
this is our given two different letters
but now let's try that same exercise
with th let's start with like at the
start of think ready nothing and now
boom like at the start of then ready
there's that vibration again exactly the
same difference as but instead both
sounds are written with the same two
letters
English has plenty of quirks like that
right I mean it sounds simple enough s
for the unvoiced Zed for the voiced well
no believing that would be unwise the
depths of how voicing slips and slides
between constants is best left for
textbook in a university lecturer
because it's really bloody complicated
but as a starting point to get you
thinking let me say this the difference
between Bob and pop is voicing so
sometimes to try and figure out where
does your voicing turn on and off during
the word pop because in most dialects
that o is voiced like in mom-and-pop
store so think about the split-second
timing required so that you say pop and
not pop or pop and then try and forget
about it because your brain will just
take care of it all for you